president Trump has taken aim again this
morning at his own attorney general Jeff
Sessions the president tweeted quote
Attorney General Jeff Sessions has taken
a very weak position on Hillary Clinton
crimes where our emails and DNC server
and Intel leaks Margaret Brennan is at
the White House with more on this story
Margaret good morning good morning well
the president is publicly attacking
Attorney General Jeff Sessions as weak
and accusing the deputy FBI director of
corruption extraordinary charges that
he's leveled in a stream of tweets asked
about sessions yesterday the president
did not answer but the Attorney General
has been the focus of the president's
ire ever since sessions recused himself
from the Russia investigation back in
March mr. Trump told The New York Times
that move was quote very unfair to the
president and yesterday on Twitter he
referred to sessions as the beleaguered
AG for failing to investigate Hillary
Clinton the Russia investigation is also
consuming mr. Trump's son-in-law my name
is Jared Kushner during closed testimony
two Senate investigators Jared Kushner
detailed four encounters with Russian
contacts and said they had nothing to do
with Russia's attempt to influence the
2016 election I did not collude with
Russia nor do I know of anyone else in
the campaign who did so Kirchner spent
more than two hours detailing
face-to-face conversations with
influential Russians
according to Kushner Russian ambassador
Sergey keys lyac suggested he meet with
Russian banker Sergey Gourcuff a friend
of Putin's who could give insight into
how Putin was viewing the new
administration and best ways to work
together at the mid December meeting
with Gore Cobb whose bank VEB is under
US sanctions Kushner said they had no
discussion about sanctions Kushner
blamed inexperience in politics for some
of the decisions while serving as a
point of contact for foreign government
officials all of my actions were proper
on one point Kushner was certain his
father-in-law won the election he said
with no help from the Russians
suggesting otherwise ridicules those who
voted for him now the White House has
not clarified whether
President Trump is trying to prompt
Attorney General Sessions to resign but
the Russia investigation is clearly on
the president's mind this morning in one
of seven tweets that he posted within an
hour the president said that Kushner
proved he did not collude with Russia
Norah of course that is going to be up
to FBI investigators to determine all
right Margaret thank you